I I haven't decided what I'm going to do
I mean I'll be honest with you
um
I I do feel
that a large chunk of the country
deserves some representation and
deserves a voice
equally
um I'm still pretty bruised by the 2015
general election how can you get four
million votes in one seat it makes it a
very difficult thing to do
I haven't decided what I'm going to do
but something's going to come along if
it's not me it'll be it'll be a Nick
Griffin Mark too you know we will we
will have a rise of something way out on
the right it's happening as we speak all
over Europe albeit aided by a proportion
representation system something is going
to change something is going to crack
and I think
coming back to UK politics uh you know I
think I've got a better understanding of
those Rebel voters than than pretty much
anybody frankly